Thanks, Susan. The first focus here is a Visuospatial sketchpad. This is
responsible for visual and spatial information. Try this close your eyes. Are
they closed? Okay, now tell me how many rows of dots there were on the screen.
Okay, open your eyes. Were you right? So for this example, the sketch pad
provides storage for information that's visual. Such as images of photos. In
this example, you're using your visual spacial sketch pad. When you were trying
to remember how many rows of dots there were on the screen. The second part of
the storage system is the episodic buffer. This is related to the storage of
inforamation that will become long term memories of specific events. And
finally, We have the Phonological loop. As the name implies, it's our memory
for sound or linguistic information. Now if we want the information that we've
learned to last, and become a long term memory, we have to rehearse it. And
this is called Rehearsal. As the name implies, rehearsal is a process of
practicing or reciting the information to ourselves. Now, go back to the
example of the letters I wanted you to remember, your Visuospatial sketchpad
allows you to see the numbers in your head. Your phonological loop allows you
to hear the numbers, and you'll need to rehears the letters if you want them
for later use.